you know the pressures on us are
overwhelming from Wall Street or our own
egos or from internal incentive
structures or our bosses whatever it is
the pressures are overwhelming for us to
play the finite game and so how do you
stand up to massive external pressure
courage and courage is something that
comes from relationships you know it's
external a world-famous trapeze artist
would never attempt a brand-new
death-defying act for the first time
without a net they would never do it so
why do we think that we could do
something difficult without external
support - I've had the opportunity to
meet real heroes people who've risked
their lives to save the lives of others
with the belief that they were gonna die
and they didn't and when asked why did
you do it they all say something similar
which is they would have done it for me
it's external and so we have to have we
have to take the time to foster and take
care of people around is to nurture our
relationships because when we're gonna
be doing something difficult when we're
gonna be swimming upstream when we're
gonna be innovating and and and and
doing something different there are days
we're gonna doubt ourselves there are
days we're gonna get knocked on our ass
there are days that storms are gonna
rise and we have to have people who say
I got you back you need to do this we
need you the world needs this keep going
I believe in you
and so courage courage comes from from
not only our willingness to do that for
others but then their willingness to do
it for us and if we commit ourselves to
a just cause and we're willing to do
those things then you know the great
thing is we take a lot of people with us
and change the world for the better and
isn't that sort of the the point of an
infinite life to leave this world in
better shape than we found it to leave
the companies that we work for in better
shape than when we started to leave our
families stronger and better capable
than them they can do without us you
know isn't that what it means to live an
infinite life that we can literally
literally live on beyond our own lives
[Music]